[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANNY STRONG: I'm Danny
Strong, the executive producer
of "Proven Innocent."
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
I'm Rachelle Lefevre,
and I play Madeline Scott.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Kelsey Grammer.
I play Saul--
Saul Bellows.
[LAUGHTER]
I play that guy.
RUSSELL HORNSBY: My
name is Russell Hornsby,
and I play Ezekiel Boudreau.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
So I just want
to start out with a
note of gratitude.
I'm a human rights
lawyer, and I spent
over 15 years dealing with
the issue of criminal justice
reform.
Many years with women behind
bars, girls behind bars.
And I just want to
thank you for taking
the stories of so
many individuals I met
and creating this
beautiful show out
of it as a way of
centering voices
that aren't usually heard.
So thank you for that.
Kelsey, of course, we're
going to start with you.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Oh, lovely.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: So
I want to understand,
this show is about
wrongful conviction,
prosecutorial overreach, if not
misconduct, forced confessions,
and really kind of surfaces
some of the brokenness
in our criminal justice system.
What made you do this?
What drew you to be part
of this kind of narrative
and storytelling?
KELSEY GRAMMER:
Oh, well first off,
which is pretty
simple in my life,
somebody offered me a job.
And that's half the battle.
Then I went and saw the pilot,
which had been shot already.
I replaced an actor that was
lovely in the performance.
But it actually gave
me an opportunity
to say, well, you know
what, there's a few things I
can offer you guys for this.
I think he needed
to be more rounded
and actually try to put a
human face on a guy that
was to be painted as
a bit of a monster
and the devil of the piece.
But he's a man of some--
oh, what's the word--
inefficiency, some
lacking, some insecurity
that lives in him that I
thought was kind of fun to play.
And he's got some power,
but it's very limited.
And he's got some courage,
but it's very limited, too.
So I like the fact that he was
a bit emasculated in his life
and that this thing, his
devotion to justice, I think
is real and genuine.
It's just also part of his 20
years in the business has been,
well, this one gets
moved through, yeah,
that one's guilty.
You make some snap
judgments within the context
of this stuff.
And unfortunately, it's a
concept or an ideal that
is administered by human
beings, and they're always
going to mess it up.
Whether or not it's--
what's the word-- deliberate
or malevolent, who knows?
I think there may
be some moments--
every lawyer, I believe, has
rehearsed with a witness.
I don't know if there's
a crime in that.
But I do think there is a
great amount of attention that
must be paid to this idea.
And if you get it
wrong, you get it wrong.
And obviously, people
have gotten it wrong.
And maybe there's
an aspect of them
not caring or trying to CYA--
Cover Your Ass-- about it.
But I found him an
interesting character.
And what's nice is I
collaborated with Danny
and said, you know what, I
don't know, I don't buy this.
Or maybe he would--
obviously, the Chicago
Police Department
does have its sort of indictable
kind of character flaws.
And some of them
even were announced
during the time we were
shooting the film, remember?
When they found
those three cops,
I guess, that had set up
like 20 different guys.
DANNY STRONG: Yeah.
KELSEY GRAMMER: They
finally let them out.
That was a cool moment.
But there are also good
people within the context
of this kind of work.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: So
how do you play him?
Do you play him as
not the villain?
Do you play him as someone
who has a good spirit,
but has been broken?
When you come into
that role, what
is it that you want to show the
audience about this individual?
KELSEY GRAMMER: Well
I wanted to make sure
that people understood that he
actually cared about his job,
that he wanted to
do a good job at it.
And thought he had.
And was honestly quite convinced
that Madeline is guilty.
And for whatever
reason that was.
We left some of
it up in the air.
There was a piece of
evidence that they never
found that left it possible.
He might still think,
well, that will prove it.
And we explored some of
this stuff in the storyline
as it goes along.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: So, Danny,
you shared this with me,
and I would love you to
share with the audience
the genesis of this series--
how it was brought
to you and what made
you decide to act on it.
Because it's not the typical
law and order kind of series
that we've been exposed to.
DANNY STRONG: Mm-hm.
Well it started with an
idea from the creator
of the show, David Elliot.
He's a screenwriter I've
known for many years,
and he came to me and said,
what about doing a show
on the Innocence Project?
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Can
you just tell people
what the Innocence Project is?
DANNY STRONG: The
Innocence Project,
it's a group of law firms--
although they're not
necessarily affiliated
with each other--
that are dedicated
to people that
have been wrongfully convicted.
That's their mission statement.
That's what they do.
And a really wonderful
organization.
And I like to do
projects that have
some sort of social
justice component to it.
I think it makes the
project worthwhile doing.
And I simultaneously think
it makes the project better.
It makes it more dramatic and
a better piece of entertainment
on top of it.
But it's just so
much more worthwhile
when you feel like you're
working on something
that has something
to say as opposed
to just pure entertainment.
And so a show, a weekly law
show on wrongful conviction
for me was a bullseye
of the kind of show
I'd like to be affiliated with.
And coincidentally,
the week before, I
had seen the Netflix
Amanda Knox documentary,
and it had enraged me.
I didn't know that
much about her case.
I just always thought, I
think she's probably innocent,
without knowing the
details of the case,
just what little I'd read.
And she was so railroaded.
And just watching the Italian
police detective discuss
her case, I had to pause
it because I started
screaming at the television.
I could not believe his logic.
And then as the
documentary goes on and on,
it just becomes more absurd.
And so at that moment,
when he had pitched me,
I'd just seen this and was wound
up about wrongful conviction.
So the timing was
absolutely perfect.
And I said, well, let's make
the lead character someone who
was wrongfully
convicted and got out
and became a wrongful
conviction attorney.
So there definitely was
a timing element of this.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: And
it has become more a part
of the conversation, right?
You do have podcasts
around those who
have been wrongfully convicted.
And you do have a lot more
attention to the Innocence
Project and those who have
been released because of DNA.
DANNY STRONG: I just want
to stay on top of that.
I don't understand why it's
just now, in the last 18 months,
becoming a conversation.
Wrongful conviction.
I mean, our justice system
isn't riddled with error.
There are people in prison that
are guilty for sure, right?
It's a justice system.
But there are people
that aren't, and it
is a grave injustice.
And so the fact that
it's now just becoming
a topic of discussion,
I don't understand
why this hasn't always
been a topic of discussion.
But I'm really proud
to be a part of it
now that it actually
is at the forefront.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Well I
think part of what plays out
is that we've had law and
order stories on television
that haven't given voice to what
you all are giving voice to.
And so that kind of movement
in the public square, discourse
around justice reform I
think has been very powerful.
So I want to talk to the actors
around how they are doing this.
Because I have to
say, as someone
who identified as
a movement lawyer,
I was really excited when I
saw Thurgood Marshall's picture
in your office and
the whole idea of what
it means to be a lawyer whose
righteous and part of a kind of
crusading way of using law as a
tool for justice and goodness.
So I would love to know
how you both prepared
for those roles of being these
kinds of righteous lawyers.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: I'm not sure.
Maybe that question is
specifically for you.
I'm not sure Madeline
is a righteous lawyer.
I think she's doing a righteous
thing, but she's complicated.
And her motivation--
she wasn't a person who
knew when she was young,
saw injustice in the world
and thought, I'm going to
do something about this.
I'm going to go to law
school and dedicate my life
to righting these wrongs.
She had a profoundly traumatic
life-changing experience.
And I think that she's fortunate
that experience, rather than--
as you see with her brother--
rather than destroy her and
continue to break her down
and continue to
re-traumatize her,
that experience awakened
something in her
and that she wants
justice because
of what happened to her.
I'm not sure that the word
righteous is right for her
as a whole.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Mm-hm.
It's about her lived experience
and doing the lawyering
from that place of
a lived experience.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: Absolutely,
because she definitely cares
about her clients and is
trying to save the people who
are wrongfully convicted.
But from my experience
living with her--
and I think we all have a
version of this in our lives,
where you try to right a
wrong for other people,
and you tell yourself
that it's pure,
and you tell yourself that
what you really want to do
is just spare other people the
hell that you went through--
but in my experience,
you're always in some way
trying to go back in
time and save yourself.
And I think that plays a part.
I think that's why,
in each episode,
she connects so deeply with
each of the characters.
There are lawyers
that I've talked
to who have suggested that
she, in the real world,
would have to actually
rein that in order
to be a really good, effective
lawyer, that you can't
be crying with your
clients all the time.
And that's OK that's what
our show is because we have
another lawyer in our
firm who is righteous
and who does hold
up that end of it.
And I'll let him speak now.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Russell.
RUSSELL HORNSBY:
Well there's the why,
and then there's the how.
So the why is because
when I read the script,
the story touched me, the
characters touched me,
the premise really touched me.
And then when I
had an opportunity
to sit down with Danny and
David Elliot, the show creator,
and just have a conversation
about what we're trying to do
and what we ultimately
want to say,
and they listened to
my thoughts and ideas
about who the
character is and where
this character was going to go.
And so then we get into the how,
and you ask about preparation.
Quite honestly, I look at
it as life prepared me.
I feel like right
now I'm in a place,
in a space, where roles
are meeting me where I am.
And so the preparation
comes from, for me,
being black in America.
It comes from, for me, knowing
that a Thurgood Marshall
exists, knowing that there was
a Frederick Douglass, knowing
that there were--
Martin Luther King, Malcolm X--
righteous leaders-- there
was the Black Panther Party--
who were out there fighting
for people, for their dignity,
for their place and their
space in this society.
And so as a man, as a
conscious member of society,
you ingest that,
you absorb that.
And that becomes part
of your narrative, that
becomes part of your story.
And what I have to
deal with day to day
as a black man in America,
what friends have to deal with,
what you read in the newspaper,
what you see on television, all
of that, you don't have
to prepare for that
because that's a part of you.
So the reason why this
narrative touched me so
is because I can then, in
turn, bring that passion,
bring that pain, bring that
anguish to bear, and bring it
and really now, as best
we can, as best I can,
touch people with my passion and
with this pain that I possess.
And through Ezekiel
Boudreau, touch people,
pierce their heart pierce their
soul so that they can say,
wow, I feel something different,
I sense something different.
Now I want to converse,
I want to communicate
with other people about
what I just witnessed,
what just touched me, how,
why did that touch me.
That's what moved me,
and that's why I'm here.
And that's the preparation that
goes into this type of work,
you know what I mean?
The saying goes, you
can't lie in life
and tell the truth on stage.
It is a part of who you are
that you're bringing to bear.
And so there's very
rare times, but it
is where these roles,
they meld with the person.
And you can bring--
I can bring Russell's
humanity to easy.
And so therefore, it ain't hard.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: I have to
say that it was a lovely touch
to see that you had
saved her, right?
Because often when we
see these kinds of shows,
black men are the
predator, the abuser.
And in this story,
there is a way
in which not only are
you the righteous lawyer,
but you saved her.
And I think that was a
really beautiful touch.
And I want to talk about that--
RUSSELL HORNSBY: Sorry.
Image is everything.
Do you know what I mean?
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Indeed.
RUSSELL HORNSBY:
I appreciate that.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: And I
want to talk about that.
Shonda Rhimes talks about how
this isn't about diversity.
This is just about when we
have inclusion in our shows,
it's just showing reality.
And I really appreciate
the kind of diversity
that exists on this show and
that is part of the cast.
And I would love to
hear you all talk
about that experience of being
intentional around who you are
as character and
together as cast
in this very
different backgrounds
that you each bring
to your performances.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: I
would like to invite
Danny to talk about the process
that was so inclusive when you
were building the writers room.
DANNY STRONG: Oh.
I mean, our writer's room
is 50% African-American,
and that's what I wanted--
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: And 50% women.
DANNY STRONG: And 50% women.
That's what I wanted
the room to be.
I thought that is
what it needed to be,
I mean, especially on a show
about wrongful conviction,
in which people of color
are so adversely affected
by wrongful conviction.
And so many people
that have been
wrongfully convicted and been
released are people of color.
So how do you do
a show like this
and not have your writers'
room, your writers,
a ton of people of
color in the room.
And then also with the casting
for the leads of the show,
for our law firm, we
have two white lawyers,
two African-American lawyers.
I thought, OK, well
that's a cool makeup
for a wrongful
conviction law firm.
And our directors, the same.
We've had many people
of color directing,
many women directing, many
women of color directing.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
You mentioned that.
DANNY STRONG: Yeah, of course.
It's been a great mix.
But I want to do that
on everything I work on,
not just because the show is
about wrongful conviction.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: Yeah.
And I think the
reason I really wanted
to have Danny say that
is also because I think
that the way that
you talk about it
represents where we
really should be,
which is the idea that
that's taken for granted.
The idea that it doesn't
have to be effortful,
that it doesn't have to be
something where you're trying
to show how aware you are.
It's just the right thing
to do to be inclusive.
It's just the best case
scenario for everybody involved.
And so I think that
in a way, as much
as these are conversations
that are weighted,
there is a certain amount
where you can kind of breathe
when you encounter people
who are where we want to go,
which is just to take these
things for granted as just
the way to be.
And so I always really
appreciate the way
that you talk about that,
that it was obvious.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Yeah,
you know what's funny?
I'm thinking back
through some of the shows
that I've produced.
On "Frasier," it was probably
70% white, 30% black writers
on the staff.
There's an old saying, though,
you write what you know.
But on "Girlfriends," I think we
had one white girl for a while.
It was mostly black.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Can I
just take a moment, though?
Because a lot of my
friends talk about this.
When I shared with them
that I was interviewing you,
they were like, he produced
"Girlfriends" and "The Game."
Kelsey Grammer did that.
And I just want to acknowledge
that, give a shout-out
to the fact that you were
supporting black content
for more than just
the moment that this
has been part of your presence
and work in Hollywood.
KELSEY GRAMMER: A
long time, yeah.
And the presumption
has always been,
well, you just hire who's good.
I mean, I've never really
put a lot of labels
on whether or not it
should be this or that.
It made sense on
"Girlfriends" to have
a bunch of girls
who were-- well,
half the girls were mixed, and
that was kind of interesting,
too.
And we had one writer that
was a mixed race there,
and that brought a
certain perspective.
But of course, when you're
collaborating on the floor,
especially in a sitcom,
the actors and the writers,
if they don't have
a communication
and a collaborative spirit
instantly about what they know,
what they can say to a writer.
No, no, no, you guys
have got this one wrong.
That's what you have to be able
to do, in that circumstance
specifically.
In a hour-long
scripted drama, there's
a little more distance
between the actor
and the writing staff as a rule.
But "Girlfriends" started 20
years ago, something like that.
I mean, it seemed as natural as
apple pie to just do that show.
I don't know.
I mean, we've always
had a diversity.
NBC always had a
diversity kind of event,
where they'd invite a few
people of Asian descent
and a couple of black people
and a couple of white people
to stand up on the stage and go,
yeah, it's more important to us
to have diversity.
And I thought, well, shit, put
your money where your mouth is.
So I went and pitched the
show, and somebody finally
said, yeah, we ought to
put that on television.
So it seemed like
a natural thing
to do, a natural expression of--
I grew up in the generation--
my grandparents
raised me mostly,
and they were colorblind people.
They said, you
don't judge anybody
based upon what they look like.
You judge them based upon
what they do, who they are.
And you take your time.
You don't judge anybody
until you get to know them.
Once you get to
know them, then you
have some information
by which to say,
no, this one's an
asshole, that one's OK.
And it's pretty elemental.
Now I think people should be
hired based upon whether or not
they're good at their job.
I do think it's great to have
as much diversity and as much
sort of openness about
wherever you come from.
As long as you show up that
day ready to work, bang,
you're my guy or girl.
It doesn't matter to me.
So, I mean, maybe that's a funny
lens, but I'm a practical guy.
It's like, I want to go to
work, I want to go home.
Soon as we're on the
set, we're going like,
what the hell is taking so long?
What the hell's going on now?
It's pretty simple stuff.
I mean, we got a French
guy that's a cameraman.
I mean, I don't know,
maybe that's something
we should find more important.
RUSSELL HORNSBY: He's waiting
for the wine at lunch.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Yeah, he's all,
(FRENCH ACCENT) Wait a minute,
we work the wrong
hours, this is terrible.
(NORMAL VOICE) But I
love the process we live.
And I love the fact that
we care enough to say,
you know what, here's an
issue we'd like to examine.
The simplest answer
to your question
about why I took this
role is somebody's
got to play the
bad guy, honestly.
Somebody has to play that.
But I believe he's a
good human being who
has made a lot of
serious mistakes,
and continues to make
them, as you will see.
But I'm suddenly
talking too much.
I find myself suddenly in
a compromising position
because the Fox
advertising people
asked me to do a fake
campaign speech for Rosemary's
Law or that sort of thing.
I actually do a speech for
that on a campaign issue
called Marcy's Law, which is
for victims' rights, which
is a weird thing.
My sister was murdered
when she was 18,
and there were three
guys that killed her.
But they also killed
seven other people.
And my dad was also murdered,
which is a different story.
But the guy that killed
my dad actually got out,
and nobody told us about it.
And we found out by accident.
I actually found out--
the National Enquirer
wrote an article about it and
said, why is this guy out,
and why is his last name Niles?
Did they do that deliberately?
Did they call his brother
Niles for a reason?
I mean, that was just
so weird and awful.
And so I thought it would be
important to start talking
about that kind of stuff.
So in the face of what we're
doing in terms of a cause
célebre, it's odd that I'm
involved in this other world
where--
I'm pro death penalty in
spirit because of the guys
that killed my sister,
but I am against it
because you would never want
to kill an innocent man.
And if you don't know
for sure, you know.
I mean, if it was up
to me, I'd kill them.
That'd be fine.
Let me take care of these two.
There's only two of them left.
But there was four
other families.
The prosecutor decided
that they would only
try for three of the murders
because those were slam dunks,
they thought.
And they left four other
families without closure kind
of.
And I thought, boy, this is
a sad thing for our justice
system.
I mean, she died in '75,
so it was a while ago.
But I'm flying out on March
15 to ask them to keep
one of these guys in jail.
Every year, he gets a chance
to say, I did my time,
I should get out.
Well, he killed seven people.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
I want to thank you
for sharing your sister's
story and for having
the courage to give voice to
what it means to have a loved
one murdered in that
way and be able to talk
about the work of the
wrongfully convicted,
to be able to hold
both realities--
KELSEY GRAMMER: You do
want to hold them both.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Absolutely.
KELSEY GRAMMER:
Because we don't want
to be a society that makes
those kind of mistakes.
We just don't want to be.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Absolutely.
And we are a better
system for being
able to hold both those places.
And the conversation
around justice
is a better one because we
can hold both of those places.
So thank you.
I come out of the
work of girls who
have been bought
and sold and seen
seeing horrible ways that they
were raped and commercialized.
And fighting for those
abusers to be held accountable
goes side by side
with the insistence
on fair and equitable justice.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Absolutely.
You can't rush to judgement,
but you got to get them.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Yes.
Yes.
So thank you for bringing
all of that present with us.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Thank you.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: I
wanted to ask each of you
to just talk about how this
series and everything that it
brings forward and all the
ways that it has asked of you
to stretch yourselves
as writers, as actors,
as producers and all of what it
has forced you to bear witness
to in terms of the stories of
the wrongfully convicted, which
are such horrible
egregious stories in terms
of their suffering, but evidence
of a broken justice system,
if you could talk
about how all of that
has changed you as a result
of your work in the series.
RUSSELL HORNSBY: It's a
challenging question to answer.
But all I can do is just
hearken back to kind
of what I said before, that it's
been ever present in my life.
The notion of the wrongfully
convicted, that it's
been a part of me and my life.
And so I don't think it hasn't
really changed me, per se.
It's just made living life a lot
more painful because now it's
ever present.
You're always aware of it,
but now it's ever present.
It's in the forefront
of your spirit.
So you listen to podcasts,
you read about things.
And now that I have
children, I cry for them,
do you know what I mean?
It pains me when I think
about these stories
or when I listen
to them or I meet
people who have been exonerated,
it's painful, quite honestly.
And so that's what continues
to give me the passion
just to move forward and to work
as hard as we do on the work,
quite honestly.
Because when people see it,
whatever they take from it,
you want to make
sure that it's full
and that it's fully something
that they can ingest and then
ultimately feel.
KELSEY GRAMMER: I'm
just glad to lend
a voice to anything
that actually
seems important at the time.
I honestly am a
witness, I suppose.
And I think probably
more important
than anything else is to witness
something that is happening,
to bring light to it
and be a part of that.
I mean, somebody told
me a long time ago--
this is not an
original thought--
great art makes
us ask questions.
If you walk away with a
question or two and say,
maybe I better check that out
or rethink this a little bit,
that's about as good as
an actor's life can get.
That you've actually
done something
that maybe someone decided one
day to take a pause and rethink
something.
So I feel quite happy
to be part of the game.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
I would echo that,
and I would say that the
experience that I had making it
was that.
And then I feel that
the way that I changed
was the way that I grew.
We had episodes
every week that dealt
with corruption for
a myriad of reasons
and all kinds of biases.
We deal with racial bias,
sexual bias, gender bias,
sexual orientation,
religious bias.
I mean, we get these
scripts, and at
the heart of every script is
a massive subject to unpack.
And we are trying to make
a television show, not
a philosophical
documentary, where we all
sit around and talk about
our feelings and experiences
and try to figure it out.
But that's what we
did behind the scenes.
Because you don't get a
script like that if you have
a cast like we have,
that is incredibly
engaged and thoughtful
and wants to participate
in the conversation, you
don't get those scripts
and then not immediately
start to brrrrup.
And it was a really
amazing thing for me.
I keep repeating
this phrase because I
think it's so important.
My sister calls it--
when we start difficult
conversations in our family,
my sister stops when we're
about to enter into challenging
territory of any kind and
she goes, wait, wait, wait,
and she announces
assumption of goodwill.
And it's such a
beautiful thing, and I've
started to do it
in my regular life,
in conversations with people
that I'm comfortable with
and people I'm
uncomfortable with.
I go, hold on, if
we're going to do
this, let's give each other--
there's a group
or individually--
let's have assumption
of goodwill.
Because these conversations
don't result in progress
unless people are
allowed to, A, be
honest in ways that
might incriminate them
in the conversation
or, B, they are
allowed to admit ignorance,
either by admission
or by demonstrating ignorance
in what they're saying.
And those things need grace.
They need the other
person not to attack,
not to launch into diatribe.
They need the other
person to just stop
and inform and educate
and offer an opportunity.
Now if the person doesn't
take the opportunity,
that's a different conversation.
But if the person is going
to take the opportunity,
the only way to know that
is to give it to them.
And that's what happened
with, as Danny pointed out,
we have a diverse cast,
and it was an opportunity
behind the scenes each time
for me to go to my castmates
and say, I understand this
only on the surface, please
can you explain this to me?
Can you broaden this for me?
Can you deepen this for me?
Or to do the opposite,
to say, actually,
I understand that you
have your back up a bit,
but let me give
you my perspective
and let me give you
an alternative way--
let me reframe that for you.
And that's how we
functioned every day on set,
and it was the most,
for that single reason--
in addition to everybody
just being lovely
and us having a great time
making a good television show--
for that reason was the single
most gratifying work experience
I've ever had.
DANNY STRONG: Amazing
cast, isn't it?
I mean, everyone
is so thoughtful
and well said and
incredible actors.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: What
was it, an assumption--
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
Assumption of goodwill.
KELSEY GRAMMER:
That's nice, yeah.
DANNY STRONG: I just had
one when I said that.
For me, what it
brought to me is what
I'm hoping that the
show brings to everyone,
which is awareness.
Awareness, empathy.
We take a look into
many people that
don't get a voice in
a mainstream platform
to give them that voice.
And for me, I'm fascinated
about learning about them
and about learning of
people that aren't myself.
I have a lot of friends that
are funny Jewish writers.
I don't need to write
a show about them.
What was that?
KELSEY GRAMMER: I was just
thinking of Mrs. Maisel.
DANNY STRONG: Yeah, yeah.
Although I love that show.
I mean, I really love that show.
KELSEY GRAMMER: There
was room for one.
DANNY STRONG: So we do
a transgender episode.
We have a death penalty
two-part episode.
We have an episode on
shaken baby syndrome.
I didn't know anything
about shaken baby syndrome.
I'm blown away by it, that
the science has been debunked.
There are women in prison who
supposedly shook their babies
to death, but the
baby just could've
fallen and hit its head.
It's a tragedy.
And so to be able to shine
a light on that issue,
I'm proud of that.
But I just want to
shine the light.
People need to know about this.
I didn't know about it.
And now we have a
platform to tell
millions of people about it, and
we do it episode after episode.
So for me, it's
about that awareness.
And there's a bias.
There's a general
bias for people
that have been found
guilty, which is, well,
if you were found guilty and
you went through this process,
you must be guilty, right?
And many of them
are guilty, right?
But for that small percentage
that isn't, perhaps
when they're now going
through the process of having
a retrial, if people in the
jury have seen the show,
they may be more empathetic.
They just want to look
deeper into this issue,
into this case.
Did this really happen?
What did really happen?
And so many wrongful convictions
that we read about in the news,
they happen because
of DNA evidence.
The person gets
released because of DNA
because that's conclusive.
Well, what about all the cases
where there is no DNA evidence?
And that is where
many of our storylines
come from those cases.
So to give that awareness,
a sense of empathy
for individuals and for
the system in its totality
is the goal of the show.
And by the way, to have a
really entertaining show.
I mean, our show is exciting.
It's cool.
It's funny.
It's emotional.
It's not just this
relentless depressing,
oh my god, this is so horrible.
And that's actually
the challenge
with the subject material,
to be able to do that.
KELSEY GRAMMER:
It's interesting--
I'm sitting here just thinking--
there's a great play
called "12 Angry Men."
Did Paddy Chayefsky write it?
DANNY STRONG: No, it
wasn't, but I don't know--
KELSEY GRAMMER: So Sidney
Lumet directed this movie.
It's fantastic.
But this is what we do.
We call attention to things that
maybe need a second look, that
make us think a little bit.
And it does, it serves
the same purpose.
It's a fantastic compelling
film about a group of jurists
sitting in a room
and that dedication
that suddenly these
12 people have
to find the right thing out.
And I think doing the
right thing is still
a wonderful focal striving.
And I'm pleased to actually be
part of a striving situation.
I'm not going to
offer any answers.
I'm just going to, like I said,
hopefully some good questions.
And it's a pleasure
to be part of it.
Thank you.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
Tell people also,
it's a small, tiny little thing,
but when people are moved,
they often ask, what can I do?
And something
interesting happened
after between the pilot and--
I became a citizen.
I'm Canadian.
I became a United States
citizen a year ago today.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Welcome.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: Thank you.
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And because I had a green
card, I'm on the list--
I don't know how the system
is, it's a bureaucracy--
but I got on the list.
I get the jury summons to go
participate and be on a jury.
And every year, I have to check
the box that says not a citizen
and send it back because
I've had my green card.
And we shot the pilot.
And then between the pilot
and doing the series,
I went home to Los
Angeles, and I got one.
And it's really bad because
I ended up having something.
I actually couldn't move,
and I couldn't do it.
But I can't believe
I'm going to say this.
It's hypocritical.
But when I got it,
my thought was, oh!
And I've just done this
show, and I'm a citizen.
show, and I shot the pilot
and I kept thinking, how
can I help, what can I do?
And this thing that I
would get in the mail that
seemed like such an
irritation, such an,
oh, I've got jury duty.
And my friends were
like, ugh, jury duty.
And I went, oh, that thing
that comes in the mail
is an invitation to
participate in the process.
And so even tiny little
things like that now my view
is sort of different.
Yeah.
KELSEY GRAMMER: It's a little
more than an invitation
actually.
It's sort of like there's
kind of a penalty involved
if you lie or don't show up.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
The invitation is
to participate with
all of what's in you
and not just sit there, I guess.
Yeah.
KELSEY GRAMMER: It's supposed
to be a privilege, I know.
But it is inconvenient
sometimes.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: It's funny.
We're having this amazing
engaged conversation
about social justice.
And then you go home and you
get your jury summons, ugh.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Very,
very nicely put.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE:
Just a thought.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Well
now when people get that
and they've seen
the show, they can
consider that there's something
like a forced confession
or prosecutorial overreach.
And those kinds of ways in
which we demystify, I think,
are important.
And who we center in the
storytelling is so critical.
So again, thank you.
And it's such a privilege
to have you here at Google.
RUSSELL HORNSBY: Thank you.
RACHELLE LEFEVRE: Thank you.
KELSEY GRAMMER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]